A couple months ago, Amanda took her buddy Erin to see the rodeo in New York City at Madison Square Garden. Amanda goes nearly every year. Erin had never been. This was the Professional Bull Riders tour. And one of the pleasures of that particular tour is the guy they have as a rodeo clown, Flint Rasmussen.
几个月前，阿曼达带着她的朋友艾琳去纽约麦迪逊广场花园看牛仔竞技表演。阿曼达几乎每年都去，而艾琳从未去过。这是职业骑牛大赛巡回赛，而该巡回赛的一大乐趣就是他们请来的牛仔竞技小丑——弗林特·拉斯穆森。
The guy's like a consummate entertainer, like consummate entertainer.
那家伙简直是个完美的表演者，真正的完美表演者。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
I mean he commands the crowd.
我的意思是，他能驾驭全场观众。
That's Amanda. Rasmussen's official title, in fact, is not rodeo clown or barrelman. It's entertainer. And unlike what you may picture in a rodeo clown, he speaks. He does a running patter the whole show, joking with the audience. He works in clown makeup and a cowboy hat, baggy gym shorts, athletic jersey. Her friend Erin totally enjoyed him.
阿曼达就是这么说的。事实上，拉斯穆森的正式头衔并不是牛仔竞技小丑或驯桶人，而是表演者。与你印象中的牛仔竞技小丑不同，他会说话。他在整个表演过程中一直在说俏皮话，与观众打趣。他化着小丑妆，戴着牛仔帽，穿着宽松的运动短裤和运动衫。她的朋友艾琳非常喜欢他。
He was constantly finding people in the crowd who had their cowboy hat on backwards.
他不断地在观众席中寻找那些把牛仔帽戴反了的人。
Yes, backwards. These were New Yorkers out for the night in Western gear, having no idea how to do it properly. Flint would have the cameramen pop them onto the JumboTron.
是的，戴反了。这些人是晚上出来穿戴西部服饰的纽约客，根本不知道该怎么穿戴才专业。弗林特会示意摄影师把他们投到大屏幕上。
I mean it was a great joke, you know. He called them Woody, like the Toy Story character.
这真是个很棒的笑话，你知道的。他管他们叫“伍迪”，就像《玩具总动员》里的那个角色一样。
That's so cold.
太冷了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Rasmussen's also an amazing dancer and great physical mimic. He can move like Michael Jackson or Elvis or, for laughs, a piece of bacon on the griddle. He dances with people in the audience. And in that show at Madison Square Garden, there came this moment. He was out in the audience, moving up the aisles. Here's Erin.
拉斯穆森还是一位出色的舞者和优秀的肢体模仿者。他能像迈克尔·杰克逊或猫王那样跳舞，或者为了搞笑，模仿煎锅上的培根。他会与观众席中的人共舞。在麦迪逊广场花园的那场表演中，出现了这样一个瞬间。他走到观众席中，沿着过道移动。这就是艾琳看到的。
He was dancing with people in the crowd, interacting with them. And a girl in her mid-20s came down to dance. And he visibly got uncomfortable, and started backing off, and asked the arena if she was too young and if this was appropriate for him to be dancing with her.
他正在和人群中的人跳舞，与他们互动。然后一个20多岁的女孩走下来跳舞。他明显变得局促不安，开始退缩，并问现场观众她是不是太年轻了，他这样和她跳舞是否合适。
And what does the arena say?
现场观众是怎么说的？
The arena is fine. The girl on the JumboTron visually gives consent, verbally gives consent, said, yes, yes, yes, yes. She was ushering him closer. As he was backing away, she was like, no, you can come closer. And he shakes his head and walks away, while she's still egging him on. But he does not want to cross a line.
现场观众觉得没问题。大屏幕上的女孩在视觉上表示同意，言语上也表示同意，说了好几个“是的”。她在招呼他靠近。当他后退时，她却说，不，你可以靠得更近。他摇了摇头走开了，而她还在怂恿他。但他不想越界。
And remember please, this is a man in clown makeup and a cowboy hat. Erin was like, wait. Has #MeToo made it to clowns?
请记住，这是一个化着小丑妆、戴着牛仔帽的男人。艾琳心想，等等，“我也是”（#MeToo）运动已经传到小丑圈了吗？
I turned over and looked at my friends. And I was like, you would not have seen this a year ago.
我转过身看着我的朋友们，我说，你在一年前绝不会看到这一幕。
Yeah.
是啊。
This is an amazing experience to see how the world is changing right in front of your eyes.
能亲眼看到世界在眼前发生变化，这真是一种奇妙的体验。
Now remember her friend Amanda had seen Flint Rasmussen many times before at Madison Square Garden. And she told me, yeah, in the past, he would dance with a young woman as comedy.
记住，她的朋友阿曼达之前在麦迪逊广场花园见过弗林特·拉斯穆森很多次。她告诉我，是的，过去他确实会和年轻女性跳舞来制造喜剧效果。
Yeah. Like very big, very exaggerated, very physical, slightly inept.
是的。动作很大，很夸张，很具肢体感，有点笨拙。
But in general, his shtick with women was fake flirting.
但总的来说，他与女性的表演风格就是假装调情。
Fake flirting, yeah, in very cartoonish, over the top.
假装调情，是的，非常卡通化，非常夸张。
And was it--
那是——
Playful.
好玩的。
And she says never threatening, never, ever creepy.
她说他从来没有威胁性，从来没有，一点也不让人觉得恶心。
And he's really floppy. And, you know, he's this middle-aged, corny guy wearing gym shorts.
他真的很灵活。你知道，他是个穿着运动短裤的中年老派男人。
But this was his first show in New York since #MeToo, the first show of this year's tour. And once Erin pointed out to Amanda how weird that moment was with the woman in the aisle, they both were like, maybe he's still finding his way. Maybe he's trying to figure out how a man in clown makeup navigates this new #MeToo world.
但这是他“我也是”运动后在纽约的第一场表演，也是今年巡演的第一场。一旦艾琳向阿曼达指出那一刻与那个过道里的女人的互动有多奇怪时，她们都觉得，也许他还在摸索。也许他正在试图弄清楚一个化着小丑妆的男人该如何适应这个新的“我也是”世界。
And they both started watching for other moments. And sure enough, at one point, Flint greeted some celebrities in the audience-- Miss USA and some other pageant winners, Miss Delaware and Miss New Jersey. Again, here's Erin.
她们两人开始留意其他的瞬间。果不其然，在某个时刻，弗林特向观众席中的一些名人打了招呼——美国小姐和其他一些选美冠军，特拉华州小姐和新泽西州小姐。同样，这是艾琳看到的。
And the JumboTron went to them. And the rodeo clown asked Madison Square Garden, should I go visit them? Should I go see them? And the JumboTron followed him. And he was photobombing them almost behind them. While the JumboTron was on the girls, he was kind of poking his head in between them with his hands up. But his hands were very visible.
大屏幕转向了她们。牛仔竞技小丑问麦迪逊广场花园的观众，我该去拜访她们吗？我该去见她们吗？大屏幕跟踪着他。他几乎是在她们身后进行“镜头乱入”。当大屏幕拍着那些女孩时，他把头探进她们中间，举起双手。但他的双手非常显眼。
It just felt like a physical manifestation of, I'm not crossing any lines. And I want everyone to see. I feel like in the past, he'd probably put his arms around them. You know, he would engage with them. They're beautiful ladies. But instead, he did not touch them. He asked the crowd, what should I do?
这就像是一种肢体语言，表达着“我没有越界”。我想要每个人都看到。我觉得在过去，他可能会搂住她们。你知道，他会与她们互动。她们是漂亮的女士。但这一次，他没有碰她们。他问人群，我该怎么做？
He asked them, what should I do? And it was like a real question?
他问他们，我该怎么做？这像是一个真正的问题吗？
It seemed like a real question.
看起来像是一个真正的问题。
So was it an anguished, what do I do?
那是一种痛苦的“我该怎么办”吗？
It was more perplexed.
更像是困惑。
Like, what do I do?
就像，我该怎么办？
Yeah. Like, what do I do? Like all of his usual shticks, something that he's done forever and ever, rodeo pageant queens, how he'd interact with beautiful women, how he would interact for all the years that he's been doing this up until this point no longer is valid.
是的。就像，“我该怎么办？”他以前所有的那些老梗，他做了很久很久的事情，关于牛仔竞技选美皇后，他多年来一直如何与美女互动，这些在此时此刻似乎不再适用了。
It seemed like this veteran showman was caught in this "damned if you do, damned if you don't" situation. There were beauty queens at the show. And it's his job. He had to do something with them.
这位资深表演者似乎陷入了一种“进退两难”的境地。表演现场有选美皇后，这是他的工作。他必须和她们做点什么。
If he would do the old fake flirting shtick, maybe that wasn't gonna play so well that particular month, when middle-aged men were losing their careers for unwanted advances on young women. But saying, what do I do? That didn't seem like a great alternative either.
如果他照搬以前那种假装调情的梗，在那一个月里可能不太行得通，当时中老年男性正因为对年轻女性的不当行为而丢掉事业。但问“我该怎么办？”似乎也不是什么好的替代方案。
It was more awkward than I expected and slightly uncomfortable.
这比我预想的更尴尬，也让人有些不舒服。
I don't know what to do right now. I remember saying that.
我当时不知道该怎么办。我记得我说了那句话。
I reached Flint Rasmussen when he was off the road and back in his home state, Montana. He does a lot of shows, but Madison Square Garden's a big deal. And so--
我联系上了弗林特·拉斯穆森，当时他刚结束巡演回到家乡蒙大拿州。他演出很多，但麦迪逊广场花园的演出意义重大。所以——
I remember the moment I stopped and said, I'm not really sure what I can do here. And I kind of put my hands up like, hi, you guys. And maybe it's not something I should say in a microphone. But I felt like I had a pretty good rapport with the crowd at that point, and they'd get what I was saying.
我记得那一刻我停下来，说，我真的不知道在这里能做什么。我当时举起手，就像是在说，嗨，你们好。也许这不该对着麦克风说。但我感觉当时我和观众建立了很好的默契，他们会明白我在说什么。
He told me that, sure, that moment might've looked awkward to somebody in the audience. But he swears he was playing it for awkwardness intentionally. He thought it would play funnier. And he said the adjustments that he made in his performance that night in New York City were not really very big.
他告诉我，当然，那一刻对观众席里的某些人来说可能看起来很尴尬，但他发誓他是有意表现出尴尬的。他认为这样演会更有趣。他说他那天晚上在纽约表演中所做的调整其实并没有那么大。
He's never been the kind of rodeo clown who would mack on women onstage. He's careful to be respectful. When he dances with any woman in the show, he says, it's just not entertaining if there's any whiff that he might be hitting on her.
他从来不是那种会在舞台上占女性便宜的牛仔竞技小丑。他很谨慎，保持尊重。他说，当他在表演中与任何女性跳舞时，如果有一丝他在调戏她的嫌疑，那就不叫表演了。
And if someone in their 20s comes down and sees what I'm doing, I don't wanna be that creepy guy dancing with the 20-year-old girl.
如果有20多岁的人下来看到我的表演，我不想成为那个与20岁女孩跳舞的令人反感的男人。
It was the perception of the woman who'd seen you before. She felt like in the past, you wouldn't have asked the crowd, what should I do? You know--
那是曾经见过你的女性的看法。她觉得在过去，你不会问观众“我该怎么办？”你知道——
Yeah, probably. I may not have said that, honestly. I don't know. I would've maybe said, hey, let's get a picture, and put my arms around them possibly, which I still will eventually do and still maybe should have.
是的，大概吧。老实说，我可能不会那样说。我不知道。我可能只会说，嘿，拍张照吧，然后可能搂住她们，这我最终还是会做的，可能也还是应该做的。
But I think any performer, if it's not on your mind, you have not turned on the television. You are not with it. It is in the back of your mind.
但我认为任何表演者，如果这不在你的脑海里，那你一定没有看电视。你没有与时俱进。这在你的潜意识里。
To hear Flint tell it, all this is no big deal. Change is happening in the culture. He noticed, took it in, and then revised how he acted onstage by turning all this into shtick. If only things were always so simple.
照弗林特的说法，这一切都没什么大不了的。文化正在发生变化。他注意到了，接受了，然后通过把这一切变成梗来修改他在台上的表演方式。如果一切都总是这么简单就好了。
Today in our program, we have stories of people who end up in situations where it is not clear at all how to proceed. And they really do feel like every option leaves them in a "damned if you do, damned if you don't" kind of place. And then, they have to figure out a path forward.
在今天的节目中，我们要讲一些人陷入了完全不知道该如何处理的情况的故事。他们确实觉得每个选项都让他们陷入了“进退两难”的境地。然后，他们必须找到前进的路。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, The Borrowers. So this is sort of an impossible choice that some refugees are going to have to make. And this is something new in the last year or two.
第一幕，借款者。这是某些难民不得不做的某种不可能的选择。这是过去一两年里出现的新情况。
And it's happening at one of the biggest and oldest refugee camps in the world, this camp called Dadaab, this vast sprawl of makeshift housing that's way out in the hot, arid plains of Kenya. Just under a quarter million people live there. Most of them fled civil war and famine just across the border in Somalia.
它发生在世界上最大、最古老的难民营之一，这个叫达达布的营地，这是一个位于肯尼亚炎热干旱平原上的广阔临时住所。有不到二十五万人居住在那里。他们大多数人是为了逃避索马里边境对面的内战和饥荒。
You should probably know we're in the middle of the largest refugee crisis since World War II. The Trump administration has pretty much stopped resettling refugees from this camp and from lots of places to here in the United States, even people with life-threatening illnesses. But the US does give food. There's bipartisan consensus in Congress on this. We are the biggest donor by far to this camp and in general around the world.
你应该知道，我们正处于二战以来最大的难民危机中。特朗普政府几乎停止了从这个营地以及许多地方重新安置难民到美国的做法，即使是那些患有危及生命疾病的人也是如此。但美国确实提供了粮食。国会对这一点有两党共识。我们是迄今为止该营地以及全球范围内最大的捐助国。
No other country is even close, though in recent years other countries have cut back. And food supplies are just not keeping pace with the number of people who need food, which brings us to the impossible choice that refugees are having to make at this camp in Kenya. It begins with food. Reporter Kevin Sieff, who until recently was The Washington Post bureau chief in Nairobi, explains.
没有其他国家能与之相比，尽管近年来其他国家削减了开支。粮食供应跟不上需要粮食的人数，这让我们回到了肯尼亚这个难民营中难民不得不面对的那个不可能的选择。它始于粮食。不久前还是《华盛顿邮报》内罗毕分社社长的记者凯文·西夫对此进行了说明。
Over the last couple of years, the food situation here went from bad to worse. The UN used to consistently provide enough food at the camp for three meals each day-- things like rice, vegetable oil, wheat flour. A lot of people told me they went from three meals a day to just one.
在过去几年里，这里的粮食状况从糟糕变得更糟。联合国过去常稳定提供营地每天三餐所需的充足粮食——比如大米、植物油、小麦粉。很多人告诉我，他们的伙食从每天三餐变成了只有一餐。
Recently, the UN has increased rations. But the situation's still pretty dire. For a bunch of bureaucratic reasons, a lot of the food that the UN gets from the US is sorghum. I didn't know what it is. And it turns out neither do the people in Dadaab.
最近，联合国增加了配给。但情况仍然相当严峻。由于一堆官僚原因，联合国从美国获得的许多食物都是高粱。我不知道那是什么。事实证明，达达布的人也不知道。
It's a kind of cereal that they have no idea how to cook and that they don't like. People usually barter it away. Hadija Ahmed, 58 years old, a single mom with three kids in the camp, she remembers when the rations were cut two years ago.
那是一种他们不知道怎么煮，而且也不喜欢的谷物。人们通常把它拿去换东西。58岁的哈迪贾·艾哈迈德是营地里带着三个孩子的单身母亲，她记得两年前配给被削减的时候。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
We used to get milk, rice, wheat flour, cooking oil, even canned tuna. But now, we don't know what's happened.
我们过去常能领到牛奶、大米、小麦粉、食用油，甚至是罐装金枪鱼。但现在，我们不知道发生了什么。
Hadija's kids started complaining that they were hungry. She's used to figuring things out. So to fill the gaps, she started going to a tiny shop in the camp. Lots of people do this. The markets are run mostly by other refugees and stocked with produce from outside the camp. Hadija asked the shopkeeper if she could take a little rice and milk on credit, thinking, I'll be able to pay this back. She also bought medicine and school uniforms. And her debt kept growing. The Kenyan government doesn't allow refugees to work outside the camp. And then after two years, this past December, the store owner had enough and cut her off.
哈迪贾的孩子开始抱怨他们很饿。她习惯于想办法解决问题。为了填补缺口，她开始去营地里的一家小店。很多人都这么做。市场主要由其他难民经营，库存来自营地外。哈迪贾问店主是否可以赊点大米和牛奶，心想，我以后能还上。她还买了药和校服。她的债务不断增加。肯尼亚政府不允许难民在营地外工作。两年后的去年十二月，店主受够了，切断了她的赊账。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
So he closed the accounts, like, this is the end of it. I went back home. I cried. My mind was full of, you know, troubles and stress. And I did not talk to the kids for a day or two.
所以他关掉了账目，说，到此为止了。我回到家。我哭了。我的脑子里充满了麻烦和压力。我一两天都没和孩子们说话。
Hadija is in debt for an impossible sum here-- $350. And now her creditor was hounding her to come up with the money.
哈迪贾在这里欠下了一笔不可能偿还的债务——350美元。现在她的债主一直在逼她拿钱。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
He keeps on asking me, why don't you pay my debt? Do you want to run away with my debt? Are you refusing to pay my debt? Busting my brains, how nagging it is.
他一直在问我，你为什么不还钱？你想带着债务逃跑吗？你是在拒绝还债吗？这让我头痛欲裂，多么烦人啊。
The guy who owns the shop is named Abdi Nor. Hadija says he came by her house with a Kenyan police officer and threatened to arrest her. She knew it could get even worse than that. People are often beaten up or killed over personal disputes.
这家店的老板叫阿卜迪·诺。哈迪贾说，他带着一名肯尼亚警察来到她家，威胁要逮捕她。她知道情况可能会变得更糟。人们经常因为个人纠纷被殴打或杀害。
There was only one solution left. The UN does have a program that will give you money, more money than most of the refugees here have ever seen. But it comes with a crazy catch. You have to return home to the country you fled. Refugees in Dadaab can get about $150 per person upfront if they agree to go back to Somalia.
只剩下唯一一个解决方案。联合国确实有一个项目会给你钱，比这里大多数难民见过的还要多。但它有一个疯狂的陷阱。你必须回到你逃离的国家。达达布的难民如果同意回到索马里，每人可以预支大约150美元。
I know how that sounds. They'll leave a relatively safe place and move back to the same war zone that they ran from. Posters all over the camp advertise this program. In one, a woman stands in a field with a bag on her back and a baby on her chest. It says, return is my choice. Hadija decided to do it.
我知道这听起来如何。他们将离开一个相对安全的地方，回到他们逃离的同一个战区。营地里到处都是这个项目的海报。其中一张海报上，一个女人背着包，胸前抱着一个婴儿站在田野里。上面写着，回家是我的选择。哈迪贾决定这样做。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
All avenues are closed for me. There's not any other alternative. I have to go because of the debt.
我所有的路都堵死了。没有其他选择。我必须走，因为债务。
She was returning to a failed state, a place she hadn't been to since 1998. The morning she was leaving for Mogadishu, I met up with her and her kids at a transit center. They were surrounded by suitcases and big plastic bags with other families who were waiting to board planes and buses back to Somalia.
她要回到一个失败的国家，一个她自1998年以来就没去过的地方。她出发前往摩加迪沙的那天早上，我在一个中转中心见到了她和她的孩子们。他们被行李箱和大的塑料袋包围着，还有其他等待登机和乘坐巴士回索马里的家庭。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
This morning.
今天早上。
Hadija's saying, I'm sad this morning. Her son and daughter are 19 and 17. She raised them in the camp alone. Her husband died years ago. They have no memories of Mogadishu. They don't want to go back.
哈迪贾说，我今天早上很难过。她的儿子和女儿分别是19岁和17岁。她独自在营地抚养他们长大。她的丈夫几年前去世了。他们对摩加迪沙没有任何记忆。他们不想回去。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
But I'm just stopping myself from crying. The kids get scared. I'm afraid they might sneak away and run away when they see me crying like this because they think I'm taking them to a bad place.
但我只是强忍着不让自己哭。孩子们很害怕。我担心当我哭成这样时，他们可能会溜走逃跑，因为他们认为我带他们去了一个糟糕的地方。
She was so worried about them running off that the night before, she slept between the two of them. Nobody was getting any real sleep, though. Her son Ahmed was a few months away from graduating high school. Now, he was dropping out and going to a place where boys his age were kidnapped by insurgents. This is Ahmed.
她太担心他们逃跑了，以至于前一天晚上，她睡在他们两人中间。不过，没有人真正睡着。她的儿子艾哈迈德离高中毕业还有几个月。现在，他不得不退学，去一个同龄男孩会被叛乱分子绑架的地方。这就是艾哈迈德。
Last night up to now, I have not slept.
从昨晚到现在，我都没睡。
You didn't sleep at all last night?
你昨晚一点都没睡？
Yeah. I was just-- I was awake, chatting with my friends, saying them goodbye. I was thinking about making new friends. It's hard to make a new friend, you know. I'm thinking about what will happen. My life is going to be dangerous because I'm going somewhere which is dangerous. And I can't trust that I can live there a long time.
是啊。我一直醒着，和朋友们聊天，向他们告别。我在想如何结交新朋友。你知道，结交新朋友很难。我在想会发生什么。我的生活将会变得危险，因为我要去一个危险的地方。而且我不敢相信我能在那儿长久地生活下去。
Do you know why your mom's making this decision?
你知道你妈妈为什么做出这个决定吗？
Yeah. I know very well. The main reason that she's going back is for us. If we were not there, she will not borrow any debt.
知道。我很清楚。她回去的主要原因是为我们。如果我们不在那儿，她就不会欠债。
It's $350, basically.
基本上是350美元。
Yeah, $350.
是的，350美元。
And that money is changing your life.
而那笔钱正在改变你的生活。
Yeah. I'm changing my life because of that money. If there was not that money, I will stay here.
是的。我正在因为那笔钱改变我的生活。如果没那笔钱，我会留在这儿。
Ahmed kept telling me how guilty he felt. He said Hadija was a good mom. When he asked for shoes, she bought them. When he was hungry, she fed him.
艾哈迈德一直在告诉我他有多内疚。他说哈迪贾是个好妈妈。当他要鞋子时，她给他买。当他饿时，她喂他。
He never thought about how she was paying for everything. He was a kid. But now he thinks maybe they wouldn't be going back to Somalia if he hadn't asked for so much.
他从未想过她是如何支付所有费用的。他是个孩子。但现在他想，如果他没有要那么多东西，也许他们就不会回到索马里了。
I'd met creditors like the one who loaned money to Hadija. They were pretty menacing guys, gangster types with dark sunglasses and jewelry, relentless in their attempts to get their money back. At one point, after talking to Hadija for a while, I was off talking to my interpreter. And he said, hey, you know her creditor, the store owner, he's here with her.
我见过像借钱给哈迪贾那样的债主。他们是相当危险的家伙，戴着墨镜和首饰的黑帮类型，在讨回钱财方面毫不留情。在和哈迪贾谈了一会儿后，我有一次去和我的翻译交谈。他说，嘿，你知道她的债主，那个店主，他正和她在一起。
And I looked over. And there he was, this guy Abdi Nor. He'd snuck into the transit center. He wanted to make sure she was leaving so he'd get all of his money back. He had no sunglasses, no jewelry. He was carrying a brown notebook with an itemized bill for Hadija.
我看了过去。果然是他，那个叫阿卜迪·诺的家伙。他溜进了中转中心。他想确保她离开了，这样他就能收回所有的钱。他没戴墨镜，没戴首饰。他拿着一个棕色的笔记本，上面有哈迪贾的逐项账单。
What's in the notebook?
笔记本里有什么？
Like this is rice, 6,508 shillings. For sugar, 5,500. And this is 4,900 in cash.
比如这是大米，6508先令。砂糖，5500。这是4900现金。
She borrowed cash?
她借了现金？
Yeah.
是的。
Total, there are about, let's see, about 15 lines with a big line under all of that that says 35,000 shillings, or $350.
总共，让我们看看，大约有15行，下面画了一道大线，上面写着35000先令，也就是350美元。
But as I spent more time with them, I realized Abdi wasn't some kind of mob boss trying to shake people down for money. He's a 23-year-old guy who still looks like a kid-- soft-spoken, a failing attempt at a mustache, sitting quietly on the ground next to Hadija. It turns out they live in the same block in the camp, and he's friends with her kids. They actually have a real relationship. That's why Abdi Nor let her take out groceries on credit from his tiny sheet metal stall in one of Dadaab's busy markets.
但随着我花更多时间与他们相处，我意识到阿卜迪并不是那种试图勒索钱财的黑帮老大。他是一个看起来还像个孩子的23岁小伙——说话轻声细语，留着不太成功的胡子，安静地坐在哈迪贾旁边的地上。原来他们住在营地的同一个区域，而且他和她的孩子们是朋友。他们实际上有着真正的交情。这就是为什么阿卜迪·诺让她可以在达达布繁忙市场的铁皮小摊赊账买杂货。
She comes to me every day while she's crying. She's saying, I don't have food for my children. I have felt very emotional because I don't want to see her children suffering. And I know her. I can't see her dying. I know her situation. So I've just allowed her to take that money from me. And the money that I have given to Hadija, that's a lot of money, almost half of my yearly earning.
她每天都哭着来找我。她说，我没有食物给我的孩子。我感到非常难过，因为我不想看到她的孩子受苦。而且我了解她。我不能看着她死去。我知道她的处境。所以我只是允许她从我这儿拿走那些钱。我给哈迪贾的那些钱，那是一大笔钱，几乎是我一年收入的一半。
Half of your yearly earning.
你一年收入的一半。
Yeah.
是的。
Hadija's debt, $350, that's the most credit Abdi Nor has ever lent out to any of his customers. Most of them are running smaller tabs with him-- $16 there, another $40 here. It adds up.
哈迪贾的债务，350美元，那是阿卜迪·诺借给任何客户的最多的信贷。他们大多数人都在他那里挂着较小的账——16美元，还有40美元。积少成多。
In total, Abdi Nor is in way more debt than Hadija-- about $1,500 to the big shops outside of the camp, mostly other Somalis living in Kenya. It scares him, the hole he's dug for himself. He says he had no choice but to cut Hadija off.
总的来说，阿卜迪·诺背负的债务比哈迪贾多得多——大约1500美元欠营地外的大商店，主要是住在肯尼亚的其他索马里人。这让他害怕，那个他为自己挖下的坑。他说他别无选择，只能切断哈迪贾的账目。
So when you were asking for your money, you could see that it was stressing her out.
所以当你要求还钱时，你能看出这让她压力很大。
Yeah. And I also feel sorry for her. But I don't have any other option. I need my money. I have a small shop. I'm about to close that shop because of this debt.
是的。我也为她感到遗憾。但我没有其他选择。我需要我的钱。我有一家小店。因为这笔债务，我快要关掉那家店了。
Do you think the police would have arrested her eventually if she had stayed?
你认为如果她留下来，警察最终会逮捕她吗？
Yeah. I think they will have come for her. Because they may also come for me. I think I may be forced to go back to Somalia because I am facing the problems they are facing also.
是的。我想他们会来找她的。因为他们也可能会来找我。我想我可能会被迫回到索马里，因为我也面临着他们正面临的问题。
I mean are you going to be in the same situation as she is? The only way to pay that debt is the same--?
我的意思是，你会处于和她一样的处境吗？偿还债务的唯一途径就是——？
It's the same way. I don't have another option.
是一样的途径。我没有其他选择。
People all over the world risk their lives in boats and with smugglers to try to get refugee status. But you can give up refugee status too. There's a name for the process-- deregistration. I followed Hadija and her family through the process. They're taken from table to table to sign forms and to give their fingerprints-- a conveyor belt of bureaucracies.
世界各地的人们冒险乘坐船只，并与走私者勾结，试图获得难民身份。但你也可以放弃难民身份。这个过程有一个名字——注销。我全程跟随哈迪贾一家经历了整个过程。他们被带到一张又一张桌子前签字、按指纹——一条官僚传送带。
OK. So now Hadija's coming.
好的。现在哈迪贾来了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
Her fingerprints are being taken now.
她的指纹现在正在被采集。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
[TAPPING]
（敲击声）
He's applying the ink on the machine.
他正在机器上涂油墨。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
Now I'm about to surrender my refugee status on this table.
现在我准备在这张桌子上放弃我的难民身份。
One of the deregistration officers then says this is the last process.
其中一名注销官员随后说，这是最后一道程序。
This is the last process.
这是最后一道程序。
So are they surrendering their refugee status? Is that what's happening?
所以他们是在放弃难民身份？这就是正在发生的事情吗？
They are surrendering their refugee status here. We are taking the fingerprint of the left thumb to show that this person has left the country to his own country.
他们在这里放弃他们的难民身份。我们正在采集左拇指的指纹，以表明此人已经离开该国回到了他自己的国家。
So after this, they are no longer refugees. They are Somalis.
所以在此之后，他们不再是难民了。他们是索马里人。
They are not refugees. Right now, they are Somali citizens, not Kenyan refugees.
他们不再是难民。现在，他们是索马里公民，而不是肯尼亚难民。
It's a big moment.
这是一个重要的时刻。
It's hard to explain the magnitude of what Hadija is giving up. She was a part of a tiny fraction of refugees who had been singled out by the UN a few years ago for possible resettlement in the United States. She says she'd already done a couple of interviews. Now, she's pulling herself out of the pipeline.
很难解释哈迪贾所放弃的东西有多么巨大。几年前，她曾是联合国挑选出的极少数可能被安置到美国的难民之一。她说她已经参加过几次面试了。现在，她正在把自己从这个流程中拉出来。
And if Hadija decided she wanted to come back from Somalia again, she would no longer be considered a refugee. It would be harder to get food and shelter and to get her kids back in school at the camp. As I watch Hadija go through this, so many of the UN and Kenyan government workers who are shuffling Hadija and all these refugees through the process tell me how terrible they feel and what a bad idea they think it is for people to go back to Somalia.
如果哈迪贾决定想从索马里再次回来，她将不再被视为难民。在营地里获得食物、住所和让孩子重返学校将变得更加困难。当我看着哈迪贾经历这一切时，许多将哈迪贾和所有这些难民送走过程的联合国和肯尼亚政府工作人员告诉我，他们感觉多么糟糕，他们认为人们回到索马里是一个多么糟糕的主意。
For the refugees now life has become some more hard. People are expecting to get resettlement. And resettlement now is-- Trump has refused them to go back. So I think some of them, they have lost hope of seeing this come. We are feeling of guilt of doing this, but because--
对于难民来说，现在的生活变得更加艰难了。人们期望得到重新安置。但现在的重新安置是——特朗普拒绝让他们回去。所以我认为他们中的一些人已经失去了看到这一切实现的希望。我们在做这件事时感到内疚，但是因为——
You feel guilty doing it.
你做这件事时感到内疚。
Yes. We feel guilty because we don't want these people to go back. We want them to stay.
是的。我们感到内疚，因为我们不希望这些人回去。我们希望他们留下。
Some refugees who've returned to Mogadishu have died in terrorist attacks. Others have already come back to Dadaab. And they've tried to warn people like Hadija that it's too dangerous. I talked to top UN officials about this, about refugees using repatriation money to pay off their debt.
一些回到摩加迪沙的难民在恐怖袭击中丧生了。另一些人已经回到了达达布。他们试图警告像哈迪贾这样的人，那里太危险了。我和联合国的高级官员谈过这件事，关于难民利用遣返金偿还债务的问题。
They say they're aware that it's a problem facing some people. They dispute that it's widespread. And they aren't ready to change the program. They say there's a need for a program like this.
他们说他们知道这是某些人面临的问题。他们反驳这是普遍现象的说法。他们还没准备好改变这个项目。他们说有必要实行这样的项目。
Some refugees don't want to live at Dadaab anymore. They need the repatriation money to restart their lives in Somalia. The real problem here, the UN said, is that it's caught in its own impossible position. It's just not getting enough foreign aid to buy food.
一些难民不想再住在达达布了。他们需要遣返金来在索马里重启生活。联合国说，这里的真正问题在于它陷入了自身的困境中。它根本没有获得足够的外国援助来购买食物。
Later, we all got on a pink bus with yellow stars on the windows and took the bumpy road out to the airstrip. The airstrip is an exclamation mark of asphalt, the only paved thing for miles, surrounded by an endless plain of lava-red sand. I've been reporting at this camp over the last few years.
后来，我们都坐上了一辆窗户上有黄色星星的粉色巴士，沿着颠簸的道路前往简易机场。机场是一条沥青铺成的感叹号，是方圆几英里内唯一铺设的东西，周围是无尽的熔岩红沙平原。过去几年我一直在营地做报道。
And I've come to think of this strip as the capital of the camp, the departure point for its luckiest and unluckiest residents. I got used to meeting families clutching their winter coats in the 100-degree heat with paperwork that named their future homes in places like Seattle and Minneapolis. Now, with refugee resettlement stalled under President Trump, those flights have pretty much stopped.
我开始把这条跑道看作是营地的首都，是其最幸运和最不幸居民的出发点。我习惯于在华氏100度的高温下遇到紧紧抓着冬大衣、拿着标有他们未来家园（如西雅图和明尼阿波利斯）文件的家庭。现在，随着特朗普总统任期内难民重新安置陷入停滞，那些航班几乎已经停止。
Instead, the planes are headed for Somalia. When Hadija and her family arrived at the airfield, she and other refugees dragged all their belongings off the bus-- suitcases, along with mattresses, Qurans, pots and pans. A few minutes later, a UN official sitting under a white tent calls out her name.
相反，飞机正飞往索马里。当哈迪贾一家到达机场时，她和其他难民把所有的行李从巴士上拖下来——行李箱，还有床垫、《古兰经》、锅碗瓢盆。几分钟后，坐在白色帐篷下的一名联合国官员叫出了她的名字。
They're in line. They're getting their money now. She's putting her fingerprints down under her name.
他们排着队。他们现在正在领钱。她在自己的名字下按下了指纹。
Her two kids are then called over.
她的两个孩子随后被叫了过去。
Kids, come over here.
孩子们，过来这儿。
And now it's her daughter's turn. She's putting her fingerprints down. OK. So there's a line of people. And there's a man with a pile of white envelopes. Each of them has a name on it. He takes the cash out of the envelope-- $100 bills-- and counts them in front of them.
现在轮到她女儿了。她正在按下指纹。好的。有一排人。有一个男人拿着一堆白色信封。每个信封上都有一个名字。他从信封里取出钱——100美元的钞票——并在他们面前数着。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
I see he counted $450. And he's handing it now to Hadija.
我看到他数了450美元。他现在正把它交给哈迪贾。
They're giving her the repatriation money right here in cash, four 100s and a 50 in US bills. That's the total for her and her son and her daughter-- $150 per person.
他们就在这里用现金给了她遣返金，四张100美元和一张50美元的美国钞票。这是她、她儿子和她女儿的总额——每人150美元。
So now Hadija's walking away. She's got the envelope with the money. And we just need to follow them.
现在哈迪贾走开了。她手里拿着装钱的信封。我们只需要跟随他们。
Let's go. We give out the money, the debt, that's what my mom said.
我们走吧。我们把钱交出去，债务，这就是我妈妈说的。
She immediately starts walking towards Abdi Nor, who somehow made it onto the airstrip. She's taking the money out. She just handed it to Abdi Nor in the white envelope.
她立即开始走向阿卜迪·诺，他不知怎么地溜进了机场跑道。她拿出钱。她刚把白色信封交给了阿卜迪·诺。
She did this right in front of UN officials, officials who are here to oversee this process that the UN calls voluntary repatriation. Around 100 feet away, a bunch of other refugees are also paying their creditors, slipping bills through the barbed wire fence at the edge of the airfield. Everywhere I look, people were settling their debts. For the moment, Hadija stood alone.
她在联合国官员面前就这样做了，这些官员在这里监督联合国所称的“自愿遣返”过程。大约100英尺外，一群其他难民也在支付他们的债主，通过机场跑道边缘的铁丝网递过钞票。我所到之处，人们都在清理债务。那一刻，哈迪贾独自站着。
So you had-- in your hand, you held the money for 30 seconds. And then you had to give it away.
所以你在手里拿着钱拿了30秒。然后你不得不把它给出去。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
Yes. Because this money I've ate long before.
是的。因为这钱我早就花掉了。
This money she ate.
这钱她花掉了。
Yeah. And why I'm leaving is because of giving it out.
是的。我之所以要走，就是为了把这钱给出去。
She had $100 left. She gave $50 of it to an older son who's staying behind in the camp. He was afraid to go. Hadija and her kids huddled around him.
她还剩下100美元。她把其中的50美元给了留在营地的大儿子。他害怕离开。哈迪贾和她的孩子们围在他身边。
They're saying goodbye to the other son. They're hugging.
他们正在和另一个儿子告别。他们在拥抱。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（非英语语音）
We are leaving now. I am leaving my son. And I am leaving you guys to say bye.
我们现在要走了。我要离开我的儿子。我留你们在这儿说再见。
OK.
好的。
They are being told to queue and go to the field.
他们被告知排队去停机坪。
OK. All right. OK.
好的。没问题。好的。
Now they're queuing for the flight.
现在他们正在排队登机。
OK. They just called her name. She walks up the steps. All right. They're pulling up the steps. Wheels up. It's flying out over the airfield, over the camp, over the shrubs. And in about five minutes, they'll probably be in Somalia.
好的。他们刚叫到她的名字。她走上台阶。好了。他们正在收起梯子。起飞了。它飞过机场，飞过营地，飞过灌木丛。大约五分钟后，他们可能就会在索马里了。
Abdi Nor looked on as Hadija and her kids, his friends, flew away. I went to meet him and asked how he was feeling.
阿卜迪·诺看着哈迪贾和她的孩子们，也就是他的朋友们，飞走了。我过去找他，问他感觉如何。
I felt happy to get my money back, but I also felt sorry for her.
我很高兴能收回我的钱，但我也为她感到遗憾。
The only other person who paid him off like this and flew to Mogadishu was another mom who went back with her daughter. Not long after they got there, a gigantic truck bomb went off in the city, killing more than 500 people, including her daughter. It was one of the deadliest terrorist attacks anywhere since 9/11.
另一个像这样还钱并飞往摩加迪沙的人是另一位带着女儿回去的母亲。他们到达那里后不久，城里发生了一起巨大的卡车炸弹爆炸事件，造成500多人死亡，包括她的女儿。这是9/11以来全球最致命的恐怖袭击之一。
After the bomb blast, I felt very emotional because I think she didn't deserve.
爆炸发生后，我感到非常难过，因为我认为她不该承受这些。
I've followed returnees back to Mogadishu. I've seen the massive, impoverished displacement camps where they end up, many of them partially controlled by Islamist extremists. They're way bleaker than Dadaab.
我跟踪报道过回到摩加迪沙的难民。我见过他们最终居住的那些巨大的、贫困的流离失所者营地，其中许多被伊斯兰极端分子部分控制。它们比达达布更加凄凉。
So when do you think you have to make your own decision?
那你觉得你什么时候必须做出自己的决定？
I don't have a deadline. But I think it's not far. It's not far. I'm thinking about it right now. It may be next month or--
我没有最后期限。但我觉得不远了。不远了。我现在正在考虑。可能是下个月，或者——
Really? You might have to go back pretty soon?
真的吗？你可能很快就得回去了？
Yes. I think so.
是的。我想是这样。
And today, I mean you saw the plane leave. That's the same plane that you would take if you went back.
而今天，我是说你看到了那架飞机起飞。如果你回去的话，那也是你要乘坐的同一架飞机。
Yes. That's the exact same plane that I will go.
是的。那正是我要乘坐的同一架飞机。
Dadaab was never the world's most hopeful place. But for so long, there was at least the possibility of escape. From across the camp, you used to be able to see the flights overhead, full of lucky people on their way to America.
达达布从来都不是世界上最有希望的地方。但长期以来，至少还有逃离的可能性。在营地对面，你过去常能看到头顶上的航班，满载着幸运的人们前往美国。
Kevin Sieff, he's a foreign correspondent for The Washington Post. Thanks to his interpreter in Kenya, Abdi Hussein. The United Nations World Food Programme needs $8 million a month in donations to support all the refugees in Kenya. They never, ever get that much.
凯文·西夫，他是《华盛顿邮报》的驻外记者。感谢他在肯尼亚的翻译阿卜迪·侯赛因。联合国世界粮食计划署每月需要800万美元的捐款来支持肯尼亚所有的难民。他们从来没有获得过那么多。
If you personally would like to help and get at least a bit more food in there, they do take donations from people, not just from governments. Go to wfp.org. Again, that's like World Food Programme, wfp.org.
如果你个人想帮忙并让那里多一点点食物，他们确实接受来自个人的捐款，不仅是来自政府。请访问wfp.org。再说一遍，就像世界粮食计划署，wfp.org。
Coming up, a parent desperate to help her kid has only one option through a perverse loophole in the law. But does she dare to use it? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一位急于帮助孩子的家长，只能通过法律中一个反常的漏洞做出选择。但她敢用吗？芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续后的一分钟内为您带来报道。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Damned If You Do, stories of people faced with options where all the options are bad. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, We Must Destroy This Family in Order to Save It.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“进退两难”，讲述了一些人面临所有选项都很糟糕的情况的故事。我们已经到达节目的第二幕。第二幕，为了拯救这个家庭，我们必须摧毁它。
So Eileen and her 19-year-old son Noah, they are not agreeing about some of the big issues, like for instance death as it occurs in Star Wars movies.
艾琳和她19岁的儿子诺亚对一些重大问题意见不一，例如《星球大战》电影中发生的死亡事件。
We don't even know that he's dead.
我们甚至不知道他死了。
Wait. Luke?
等等。卢克吗？
We don't know that he's dead. They say that all the time.
我们不知道他死了。他们总是那么说。
When a Jedi evaporates, it's the same thing that happened with Yoda. Their physical body's gone, but their Jedi spirit's around. I mean jeez. You're from--
当绝地武士蒸发时，这和尤达身上发生的事情是一样的。他们的肉体消失了，但他们的绝地灵魂还在。天哪。你是从——
What do I know? I'm just a mom.
我知道什么？我只是个妈妈。
Yeah. You're just a mom. Come back to me when you know what you're talking about.
是啊。你只是个妈妈。等你懂得自己在说什么的时候再来找我。
They live in the Chicago suburbs, have two dogs, go on vacations to Florida, get along well enough, as you can hear. But it took a while to get there. In fact, as a parent, Eileen had to deal with the kinds of decisions that other parents fear that they're going to have to make. And this story is about this one moment in Noah's life when Eileen faced the toughest of those decisions. Shannon Heffernan tells the story.
他们住在芝加哥郊区，养了两条狗，去佛罗里达度假，相处得还算不错，正如你所听到的。但达到这一点花了一段时间。事实上，作为一名家长，艾琳必须处理其他家长担心的那种决定。这个故事讲述的是诺亚生活中的一个时刻，当时艾琳面临这些决定中最艰难的一个。香农·赫弗南讲述了这个故事。
Noah's problem started when he was little. He'd throw fits, like not standard kid fits-- shrieking, kicking, completely uncontrollable for hours.
诺亚的问题始于他小时候。他会发脾气，不是那种标准的孩子发脾气——尖叫、踢打，几个小时完全无法控制。
He would run from one end to the other down this hallway. And he would literally bounce himself off a wall. Like he needed that pressure on him to stop his impulses.
他会从走廊的一头跑到另一头。他真的会让自己撞在墙上。好像他需要那种压力来停止他的冲动。
His diagnoses started when he was around five-- ADHD, obsessive compulsive disorder, oppositional defiant disorder, mood disorder. He'd pull out his own hair, so he had bald patches on his head. But Eileen's a nurse, has a calm, can-do attitude in emergency situations. Blood and guts is a matter of routine.
他的诊断始于他五岁左右——多动症（ADHD）、强迫症（OCD）、对立违抗性障碍、情绪障碍。他会拔自己的头发，所以头上有秃块。但艾琳是一名护士，在紧急情况下有一种冷静、能干的态度。血和内脏对她来说是例行公事。
So she found solutions, like pillow therapy. She'd put a pillow over Noah and lay on top of him. The pressure calmed him. By the time he was in kindergarten, doctors had put him on a bunch of different meds. Noah asked why he had to take them. Eileen was like, no problem. And she explained.
所以她找到了解决方案，比如枕头疗法。她会把枕头放在诺亚身上，然后躺在他上面。压力让他平静了下来。等到他上幼儿园时，医生已经给他开了许多不同的药物。诺亚问他为什么要吃药。艾琳说，没问题，然后她解释了。
I sat down with a piece of paper and crayons or markers or something. And I said, look, this is what a normal brain looks like. See how all the pathways connect? Your brain tried to form right, but your brain is kind of like a bowl of spaghetti. Sometimes the connections are there.
我拿出一张纸和蜡笔或记号笔之类的东西坐下来。我说，看，这是正常大脑的样子。看到所有路径是如何连接的吗？你的大脑尝试正常形成，但你的大脑有点像一碗意大利面。有时连接在那儿。
And sometimes there's a blockage, and then it had to grow a different way. So when you're having issues, your brain is trying to make it go through here. And then it gets blocked. And that's why you have to take medication.
有时会出现阻塞，然后它必须以不同的方式生长。所以当你遇到问题时，你的大脑正试图让它通过这里。然后它被阻塞了。这就是为什么你必须吃药的原因。
Still, they constantly had to change his meds. Sometimes, it seemed like nothing worked. As Noah got bigger, his outbursts got scarier. When he was about 10 at an Easter brunch, Noah showed up in the doorway with a carving knife and said he was going to stab himself.
尽管如此，他们不得不经常更换他的药物。有时，似乎什么都不起作用。随着诺亚长大，他的爆发变得更可怕。当他大约10岁时，在复活节早午餐上，诺亚出现在门口拿着一把切肉刀，说他要自残。
When Noah's family couldn't get the knife away from him, they called 911. The cops got the knife away, and the paramedics took him to the emergency room. Eileen started finding knives hidden under the couch. She worried what Noah might do to himself.
当诺亚的家人无法从他手中夺下刀子时，他们拨打了911。警察夺下了刀子，护理人员带他去了急诊室。艾琳开始发现藏在沙发下的刀子。她担心诺亚可能会对自己做什么。
She also worried about her daughter Bridget. She's seven years younger than Noah. In middle school, Noah would go into these rages, throw things, shove furniture. He never hurt her, but it was scary. Eileen would tell Bridget--
她也担心她的女儿布里奇特。她比诺亚小七岁。在初中时，诺亚会陷入狂怒，扔东西，推家具。他从未伤害过她，但这很可怕。艾琳会告诉布里奇特——
Go in the car and lock the door. Because I knew I could still see her. She was safer in the car. He couldn't get in the car. And then I would go in the car as well at some point. And then he'd be outside the car screaming and yelling and pounding on the car.
去车里把门锁上。因为我知道我还能看到她。她在车里更安全。他进不去车里。然后我也在某个时候去车里。然后他会在车外尖叫、怒吼，捶打车子。
Noah's 19 now. The explosions were as frightening to him as they were to the people around him.
诺亚现在19岁了。这些爆发对他自己和周围的人来说同样可怕。
It was scary. It was very scary. Because it's the type of thing where you have a random burst of uncontrollable actions.
那很可怕。非常可怕。因为这就像是你会有一次随机的、无法控制的行动爆发。
When he began to calm down, it was like waking up from a nightmare.
当他开始平静下来时，就像从噩梦中醒来。
And when you awake, it's like you're scared of what you just did. So it was this type of thing where, when I awoke from it, I saw there was things broken on the wall. There was a lot of knives thrown everywhere, things broken, things on the floor.
当你醒来时，就像你害怕你刚刚做的事情。所以这是那种事情，当我从它中醒来时，我看到墙上破了东西。到处都是扔的刀子，东西碎了，地板上有东西。
Sometimes it would be so intense that I'm not conscious of what I was doing. It was a thing where like it ate at me, really, because day in and day out, I always thought to myself, oh my god. What if I really hurt someone? And I don't know what I'm going to do.
有时它会非常强烈，以至于我没有意识到我在做什么。就像它真的吞噬了我，因为日复一日，我总是对自己说，天哪。如果我真的伤害了某人怎么办？我不知道我要做什么。
Eileen met Noah before she was actually his mom. She was a neonatal nurse working the night shift. He was a preemie, only 1 pound, 7 ounces. He had drugs in his system from his birth mom. She disappeared on him, left him at the hospital.
艾琳在成为他妈妈之前就认识诺亚了。她是一名上夜班的新生儿科护士。他是一个早产儿，只有1磅7盎司。他出生时体内有来自他亲生母亲的药物。她在他身上消失了，把他留在了医院。
Child welfare workers said he'd be hard to find a home for because he was so medically fragile. They said he would probably end up in a special kind of nursing home for babies. And that broke Eileen's heart. And so she decided to adopt him.
儿童福利工作者说，他很难找到一个家，因为他身体太虚弱了。他们说他可能会最终住进一种专门为婴儿提供的疗养院。这伤透了艾琳的心。于是她决定收养他。
She was single. She didn't have a lot of money. And she knew Noah needed lots of help. But she thought, I've always wanted to be a mother. I'm a nurse. Who better than me? She borrowed a car seat and crib from a friend, filled out all the necessary paperwork with DCFS, the Department of Children and Family Services, and took Noah home.
她是单身。她没多少钱。而且她知道诺亚需要很多帮助。但她心想，我一直想成为母亲。我是护士。还有谁比我更好？她向朋友借了一个汽车安全座椅和婴儿床，填写了所有必要的文书工作，交给儿童和家庭服务部（DCFS），然后把诺亚带回了家。
When he was a baby, Eileen brought him everywhere with her. He was easy. But as he got older and started having these meltdowns, she says her friends and family stopped inviting them over. She calls mental illness a no casserole disease.
当他还是婴儿时，艾琳带他去哪儿都带着他。他很乖。但随着他长大，开始出现这些崩溃，她说她的朋友和家人不再邀请他们过去了。她称精神疾病为“没砂锅病的病”。
If your kid has cancer, people show up on your doorstep with casseroles. If your kid is hospitalized with mental health, everybody runs away.
如果你的孩子得了癌症，人们会带着砂锅菜出现在你的门口。如果你的孩子因为精神健康问题住院，每个人都会跑掉。
From the time he was five, Noah sometimes wound up in the hospital for psychiatric care, sometimes for weeks at a time. Remember, Noah had been abandoned by his biological parents as a newborn. So Eileen always reassured him that she wasn't going to leave him there.
从他五岁开始，诺亚有时会最终住院接受精神病护理，有时一住就是几周。记住，诺亚刚出生就被亲生父母遗弃了。所以艾琳总是向他保证她不会把他留在那里。
Yeah. I always would promise him, yes, I'm coming back. I promise I will not leave you. I've said that his whole life, that I'm not going anywhere. You're stuck with me.
是啊。我总是向他承诺，是的，我会回来的。我保证我不会离开你。我这辈子都这么说，我哪儿也不去。你被我粘住了。
By the time Noah reached high school, Eileen estimates he'd been hospitalized 30 times. She says police and paramedics knew them by name. That's how much she called 911. Noah's doctor started saying they had to stop dealing with his illness in crisis mode. He should go to residential care, a facility, get 24-hour supervision, live there for months at a time.
当诺亚上高中时，艾琳估计他已经住院30次了。她说警察和医护人员都认识他们。这就是为什么她拨打了那么多911的原因。诺亚的医生开始说他们必须停止在危机模式下处理他的疾病。他应该去住院护理，一个设施，获得24小时监护，在那里生活几个月。
Social workers said the same thing. The kind of intensive services Noah needed if he wanted to stay at home, they were too expensive for Eileen, for most people. But Eileen wasn't sure about residential. She couldn't stand the idea of Noah being in an institution. But she worried if she didn't do something soon, he'd end up in juvie, or he would hurt himself.
社会工作者也说了同样的话。如果他想留在家里，诺亚需要的密集服务对于艾琳来说太贵了，对大多数人也是如此。但艾琳不确定住院治疗。她无法忍受诺亚在机构里的想法。但她担心如果不尽快做点什么，他最终会进少管所，或者他会伤害自己。
Because he had said multiple times that that's what he was thinking about. And I never really believed him. But I didn't want to be that parent who people would say on the news-- they'd be sitting at home and going, well, how did she not see the signs? My god, he was in the hospital 30 different times. How did she not know? I wasn't going to be that person that didn't try every single thing they could. Better off that he's mad at me than he's no longer here.
因为他曾多次说过那是他在考虑的事情。我从来没真正相信他。但我不想成为那种人们会在新闻上说的人——他们会坐在家里说，嗯，她怎么没看到迹象？天哪，他住院了30次。她怎么会不知道？我不想成为那种没有尝试一切可能的人。他生我的气总比他不再这里要好。
Well, I was more than mad. I was beyond mad. For a time, I hated-- I hated everybody for a time. But looking back, I mean I did do some very bad things, some of the stuff I told you about. But I'm not going to say it on live radio because I don't want to be perceived as a monster. But I mean, yeah, I did very, very stupid things.
嗯，我不仅是生气。我气疯了。有一段时间，我恨——有一段时间我恨每个人。但回想起来，我确实做了一些非常糟糕的事情，一些我告诉你过的事情。但我不会在直播电台里说出来，因为我不想被视为怪物。但我的意思是，是的，我做了非常、非常愚蠢的事情。
Eileen started calling around to residential homes. But none of them had an open bed for a kid on public aid, which was Noah's situation. She considered paying for a residential place on her own. But when she did the math, it came out to about $100,000 for six months. There was no way she could afford it.
艾琳开始到处打电话联系住院护理中心。但没有一个为依赖公共援助的孩子提供空床位，这就是诺亚的情况。她考虑过自己支付住院费用。但当她计算时，六个月的费用大约是10万美元。她根本负担不起。
So Eileen worked her way up the chain of command, hoping someone could find a facility the state would pay for. She called social workers, state representatives. She says she even got the governor on the phone.
所以艾琳向上级报告，希望有人能找到一个政府愿意支付的设施。她打电话给社会工作者、州代表。她说她甚至接通了州长的电话。
I talked to the governor myself. He got on the phone and said, hi, this is me. I had literally three minutes with him.
我亲自和州长谈过。他拿起电话说，嗨，是我。我确实和他谈了三分钟。
That didn't really lead anywhere. She felt like she hit a wall. And then she heard about another option, a radical one, a last resort. Eileen talked to a mom who had been in a similar situation to hers, Toni Hoy.
这并没有真正带来什么结果。她觉得自己碰壁了。然后她听说了另一个选择，一个激进的选择，最后的手段。艾琳和一个情况和她相似的妈妈托尼·霍伊谈过。
And what Toni had done to get her kid treatment was give up custody of him, hand him over to the state. Once the state takes custody of a child, they have to provide mental health care. It's a perverse legal loophole that exists in a bunch of states. It's called a psychiatric lockout. It's meant to ensure that kids who are abandoned by their parents end up with the care that they need.
而托尼为了让她的孩子得到治疗所做的就是放弃对他的监护权，把他交给国家。一旦国家获得孩子的监护权，他们就必须提供精神卫生保健。这是在许多州都存在的反常法律漏洞。它被称为“精神锁定”（psychiatric lockout）。它的本意是确保那些被父母遗弃的孩子最终能得到他们需要的照顾。
But instead, desperate parents like Eileen are using it as a last-ditch effort of making sure their kids get treatment. It's called a lockout because it's as if the kid has been locked out of their house. Some child welfare workers even tell parents to do it. It's called lockout coaching.
但相反，像艾琳这样绝望的家长正在将其作为确保孩子得到治疗的最后努力。它被称为锁定，因为好像孩子被锁在门外了。一些儿童福利工作者甚至告诉家长这样做。这被称为“锁定教练”。
The way it would work is the next time Noah was hospitalized, Eileen would refuse to pick him up and bring him home. Eventually, the state would take custody of him and pay for him to live in a residential facility. And that was it. Technically, it was easy. Emotionally, of course, it was much harder.
它的运作方式是，诺亚下次住院时，艾琳会拒绝接他回家。最终，国家将获得他的监护权，并支付他在住院设施生活的费用。就是这样。从技术上讲，这很容易。在情感上，当然，这要困难得多。
Was there any part of you just that had an emotional reaction to the idea of giving up custody, that that just felt--?
你有没有任何一部分对放弃监护权的想法有情绪反应，这感觉——？
Ugh. Absolutely. Because I'd been fighting for him my whole life. And I promised him, I will never, ever, ever, ever give you away-- ever.
呃。绝对有。因为我这一辈子都在为他战斗。而且我向他保证，我永远、永远、永远不会把你送走——永远不会。
Toni actually advised Eileen against it. She had done it and regretted it. Eileen felt like she was stuck between two terrible options-- give up custody and get Noah into residential care or keep custody and try to deal with the threadbare services they had now, which felt like failing Noah, endangering him even.
托尼实际上建议艾琳不要这样做。她做过并感到后悔。艾琳觉得她被夹在两个可怕的选项之间——放弃监护权并让诺亚进入住院护理，或者保留监护权并试图应对他们现在拥有的破旧服务，这感觉就像让诺亚失望，甚至危及他。
You don't sleep. You don't-- you just try to think, OK. Is this my only choice? What could be the worst that could happen? Could it be any worse than what you're living right now?
你不睡觉。你不想——你只是试图思考，好吧。这是我唯一的选择吗？可能会发生的最坏情况是什么？能比你现在经历的情况更糟吗？
Eileen was on the fence, so she didn't mention it to Noah. She didn't want to create more stress for him if it wasn't going to happen. Then, when he was 14, Noah had two back-to-back episodes. The first one landed him in the hospital for five days. The second one started after he'd only been home for a few hours.
艾琳犹豫不决，所以她没告诉诺亚。如果这件事不会发生，她不想给他制造更多的压力。然后，当他14岁时，诺亚连续发生了两次发作。第一次让他住院了五天。第二次是在他回家仅仅几个小时后就开始了。
Eileen and Noah got in a fight over the car keys. Eileen says she doesn't think Noah was trying to hurt her, but the struggle got physical. And she got scared. It was one of those times Bridget wound up hiding in the car. Eileen called 911, and the paramedics took Noah back to the hospital.
艾琳和诺亚因为车钥匙发生了争吵。艾琳说她不认为诺亚试图伤害她，但冲突变得激烈了。她害怕了。那次布里奇特最终躲在了车里。艾琳拨打了911，医护人员把诺亚带回了医院。
I knew I couldn't bring him back home. Poor Bridget, you know. I mean you look at your other child, and they have to lock themselves in a car. And it's not like I'm choosing one child over the other. But when you have two kids, you have to make them both safe.
我知道我不能把他带回家了。可怜的布里奇特，你知道。我的意思是，你看着你的另一个孩子，他们不得不把自己锁在车里。这不是说我在两个孩子之间选一个。但当你有两个孩子时，你必须让他们两个都安全。
And that was when she decided to do the lockout. She thought she'd only lose custody temporarily, only while Noah needed residential treatment. So the whole thing would be short-term. What she didn't fully grasp at the time was that some parents go years without seeing their kid when they do a lockout. Some parents lose custody of their kids permanently.
这就是她决定进行锁定的那一刻。她以为她只会暂时失去监护权，只在诺亚需要住院治疗期间。所以整个过程会是短期的。她当时没有完全理解的是，有些父母在锁定后几年都没见过他们的孩子。有些父母永久失去了孩子的监护权。
So Noah went back to the hospital. And after his allotted number of days in treatment, when his caseworker told Eileen he was ready to go home--
所以诺亚回到了医院。在他的治疗天数用完后，当他的社会工作者告诉艾琳他准备好回家了——
I said, I'm not coming to get him. What do you mean you're not coming to get him? I'm not coming to get him. He needs to go to residential.
我说，我不去接他。什么意思你不去接他？我不去接他。他需要去住院护理。
The hospital called again and again. And every time, she'd say the same thing. I won't come to get my son.
医院一遍又一遍地打电话。每次，她都说同样的话。我不会来接我的儿子。
And then the guy from billing would call and say, you have to come get him. Every day that you don't come get him, it's going to cost you thousands of dollars, whatever the price was. I said, I'm not coming to get him. So I think after two days or something of refusal to come get him, they said, well, we're going to have to call DCFS. I said, OK, go ahead.
然后账单部门的人会打电话说，你必须来接他。你每一天不来接他，都要花费你数千美元，无论价格是多少。我说，我不去接他。所以我想在拒绝来接他两天左右后，他们说，好吧，我们必须给儿童和家庭服务部（DCFS）打电话。我说，好的，去吧。
Somewhere about the seventh or eighth day, and I'm wondering, why the hell am I still here? Why-- why aren't they going anywhere? So I called her. And then she explained it to me.
在第七或第八天左右，我在想，我到底为什么还在这里？为什么——为什么他们哪儿都不去？所以我打电话给她。然后她向我解释了。
And what was your reaction? What did you think when you heard that?
你的反应是什么？当你听到这个时你在想什么？
Oh, I was mad. I was mad. I was sad, hurt, betrayed, a lot of emotions going through my head. And at that point, I just called her out on her name. And I said, I don't want you a part of my life. And I said, if you don't care enough about me to keep me and to push through everything, then I don't know why you ever adopted me.
哦，我气疯了。我气疯了。我很难过，受伤，被背叛，很多情绪涌上心头。那一刻，我只是当面叫她的名字。我说，我不想让你参与我的生活。我说，如果你不够关心我，不能把我留住并度过一切，那我不知道你当初为什么要收养我。
He's like, but you said you would never do this to me. You said you would never give me away. Oh, yeah, it's heartwrenching. He's believing that I am sick of this and that I want him gone.
他说，但你说过你永远不会对我做这种事。你说过你永远不会把我送走。哦，是的，这太令人心碎了。他相信我受够了这一切，我想让他离开。
So how did you explain it to him? Like what did you say?
那你怎么向他解释的？你说了什么？
I would just keep saying, you are my son. You are always my son. I love you. I loved you from the day you were born. I will love you to the day I die and then beyond. We're doing this because you know you need to be in residential treatment.
我就一直说，你是我的儿子。你永远是我的儿子。我爱你。我从你出生那天起就爱你。我会爱你到我死的那一天，甚至更久。我们这么做是因为你知道你需要接受住院治疗。
She tried to convince him that she wasn't really giving up custody. It was just a formality, just some words they had to use so the state could come and give him treatment.
她试图让他相信她并不是真的放弃监护权。这只是一个形式，只是他们必须使用的一些词，以便国家能过来给他治疗。
Trying to convince him that this was really in his best interest.
试图让他相信这真的对他最有利。
And was he convinced?
他被说服了吗？
I think sometimes, and sometimes not.
我想有时被说服了，有时没有。
And were you convinced?
你被说服了吗？
No, not always.
不，不总是。
And when your mom said, hey, we are doing this to get you treatment, did you believe her?
当你的妈妈说，嘿，我们这么做是为了让你接受治疗时，你相信她吗？
Not really, no. No. I didn't believe her, no. I honestly felt like that she-- I felt like it was her plan all along to give up on me. That's how emotionally stressed I was. I thought that this was your plan. 14 years, and then you're just going to give up on me. That's how I felt. Then I didn't talk to her really for the next 30, 40 days.
并不真的，没有。没有。我没相信她，没有。我真诚地觉得她——我觉得这是她一直计划放弃我。我当时情绪压力太大了。我以为这是你的计划。14年，然后你就要放弃我。我当时就是这种感觉。然后我接下来30、40天都没有真正和她说话。
Did you feel guilty at that moment?
那一刻你感到内疚吗？
Oh, yeah. Because you go through-- even though I tried everything for so many years and been through so much, what could I have done differently? If I had done this differently way back, would that have changed the chain of events? Yeah. You go through all of that in your mind.
哦，是的。因为你经历——尽管我多年来尝试了一切，经历了这么多，我有什么可以做得不同的吗？如果我很久以前以不同的方式做这件事，那会改变事件链吗？是的。你在脑海里一遍又一遍地经历这一切。
For weeks, Noah sat in the hospital, and Eileen didn't visit him. Because she worried if she showed up, the state would force her to take him home. And the whole plan would fail. It was hard not to see him.
几个星期，诺亚一直住在医院里，艾琳没有去看他。因为她担心如果她出现，国家会强迫她带他回家。整个计划就会失败。不看他很难。
But Eileen channeled her energies into finding a residential treatment facility for him. Some of them had terrible reputations. They seemed more like prisons. But she found a place outside Chicago called Allendale. It looked nice.
但艾琳把精力投入到为他寻找住院治疗设施上。其中一些名声很差。它们看起来更像监狱。但她在芝加哥外找到了一个地方，叫阿伦代尔。它看起来不错。
She called and made sure they had an open bed. DCFS agreed to send him there. And after spending about a month in the hospital, Noah was transferred to Allendale. Eileen had wanted to drive him to Allendale herself.
她打电话确认他们有空床位。儿童和家庭服务部（DCFS）同意把他送到那里。在医院待了一个月后，诺亚被转到了阿伦代尔。艾琳想亲自开车送他去阿伦代尔。
But DCFS wouldn't let her. The state was now his custodial parent. So she drove up on her own. Now that he was there, she could visit him again.
但儿童和家庭服务部不允许她这么做。国家现在是他的监护人。所以她自己开车去了。既然他在那儿，她又能去看他了。
I brought up his things. I brought up sheets, and blankets, and things to try and make his room feel more homey. I just wanted to be there to support him and to show him that this is not what I want to do. I'm doing this so that you can get in there. I wasn't going to abandon him.
我带来了他的东西。我带来了床单、毯子和东西，试图让他的房间感觉更像家。我只是想在那儿支持他，向他表明这不是我想做的。我这么做是为了让你能进去。我不会抛弃他。
To Eileen, Allendale looked like a summer camp.
对艾琳来说，阿伦代尔看起来像个夏令营。
There's a beautiful lake there. And there's lots of green, lots of grass, baseball fields, a farm area. I said, Noah, it looks really pretty. It looks OK.
那儿有一个美丽的湖。还有很多绿色，很多草地，棒球场，农场区。我说，诺亚，它看起来真的很漂亮。它看起来还不错。
I kind of took a relaxing breath and thought, OK. We were on the right track. I felt like we finally got what he needed and that this was an OK decision.
我松了一口气，心想，好吧。我们走在正确的轨道上。我觉得我们终于得到了他需要的东西，这是一个正确的决定。
As painful as it was to make that trade, to give up custody of her 14-year-old son in return for treatment, in that moment, it felt like it was worth it. The relief didn't last long. A couple weeks after he arrived there, Eileen got a call from DCFS saying that she needed to come to court, that she could be charged with neglect.
尽管做那个交易——放弃14岁儿子的监护权以换取治疗——是痛苦的，但在那一刻，感觉是值得的。这种解脱感并没有持续多久。他到达那里几周后，艾琳接到儿童和家庭服务部的电话，说她需要出庭，她可能会被指控忽视。
Eileen didn't know that. A lawyer told me this is a pretty common tactic to try to scare the parents into ending the lockout. And it did scare her. She tried to explain to them.
艾琳不知道那一点。一位律师告诉我，这是一个相当普遍的策略，旨在吓唬家长结束锁定。它确实吓坏了她。她试图向他们解释。
I said, well, I don't abuse him. What? You know, I went through the whole thing about I've been taking care of him for all this time. There's no abuse. There's no neglect.
我说，嗯，我没有虐待他。什么？你知道，我经历了这一切，我已经照顾他这么久了。没有虐待。没有忽视。
I was told that if I did this lockout, this was the only way for me to get him into this program. I didn't just do this because I don't want him. I'm there all the time.
我被告知，如果我进行这种锁定，这是我让他进入这个项目的唯一途径。我不是仅仅因为我不想要他才做这件事。我一直都在那儿。
The first time Eileen appeared in court, the judge told her to get an attorney. He told her this was serious. Not only could she permanently lose custody of Noah, she could lose Bridget too-- and her nursing license.
第一次艾琳出庭时，法官告诉她找个律师。他告诉她这很严重。她不仅可能永久失去诺亚的监护权，还可能失去布里奇特——还有她的护士执照。
You leave those court doors. What happens?
你离开那些法庭大门。发生了什么？
Just I went in the bathroom. You know, you just go in a stall, and you just try to get yourself together enough to make it to the car. And then I get in the car, and I already start-- I'm sitting in a parking lot making phone calls, saying, oh my god. What could I do now?
只是我去了厕所。你知道，你只是进了一个隔间，你试图让自己足够冷静以便能开车。然后我上了车，我已经开始——我坐在停车场里打电话，说，天哪。我现在能做什么？
She called Toni, the woman who had explained lockouts to her in the first place. And Toni put her in touch with an attorney who had worked on other cases like Eileen's, kind of a superstar in this world. The lawyer was able to get Eileen custody of Noah again, while getting the state to still pay for Allendale-- which is a way better outcome than many parents got and way better than the choices Eileen had at the beginning.
她打电话给托尼，那个首先向她解释锁定情况的女人。托尼联系了一位曾处理过类似艾琳案例的律师，在这个领域算是巨星。律师能够让艾琳重新获得诺亚的监护权，同时让国家继续为阿伦代尔支付费用——这比许多家长得到的结果要好得多，也比艾琳最初的选择要好得多。
In 2015, not long after Noah went to Allendale, Illinois implemented a new law that was supposed to keep lockouts from happening. But it hasn't really worked. In 2016, DCFS got 173 psychiatric lockout calls.
2015年，诺亚去阿伦代尔后不久，伊利诺伊州实施了一项新法律，旨在阻止锁定的发生。但它并没有真正奏效。2016年，儿童和家庭服务部接到了173个精神锁定电话。
This whole thing could probably be avoided if we did what basically everyone-- DCFS workers, mental health policy wonks, activists-- say we need to do-- provide kids like Noah with services in the home, the earlier the better. It would be expensive. But then, at least in most cases, we could avoid this whole weird thing of lockouts and sending kids to live in institutions.
如果我们要么做基本上每个人——儿童和家庭服务部员工、心理健康政策专家、活动家——所说我们需要做的事情，这件事本来是可以避免的——为像诺亚这样的孩子提供家庭内服务，越早越好。这会很昂贵。但那样的话，至少在大多数情况下，我们可以避免这种关于锁定和送孩子去机构生活的奇怪事情。
Noah had a terrible experience at Allendale. He was there for over two years. He hated it.
诺亚在阿伦代尔有糟糕的经历。他在那儿待了两年多。他讨厌那里。
It was beyond hate. I mean honestly, there were so many things wrong there. I was there when a staff murdered a kid.
那是超越仇恨的。我的意思是老实说，那里有太多问题了。当一名员工谋杀一个孩子时，我正在那儿。
This incident Noah's talking about, a kid died after being restrained by a staff member in a chokehold. The man was charged with involuntary manslaughter, not murder, and eventually pled to the lesser charge of obstruction of justice. Allendale, by the way, says they put procedures in place to make sure this kind of thing never happens again. Eileen says it's only in the last few months that her relationship with Noah has recovered. Now, they give each other crap in a loving way.
诺亚所说的这个事件，一个孩子在被一名员工锁喉制服后死亡。该男子被指控过失杀人，而不是谋杀，最终承认了较轻的妨碍司法罪。阿伦代尔顺便说一句，说他们已经采取了程序，以确保这种事情再也不会发生。艾琳说，她的关系与诺亚恢复是在过去几个月里。现在，他们以一种充满爱的方式互相挖苦。
Now, most of the time, you are right. Most of the time, you are right. But--
现在，大多数时候，你是对的。大多数时候，你是对的。但是——
I have two witnesses to that.
我有两个证人。
It's on the record.
记录在案。
And it's on tape.
而且有录音。
But for the times that you are wrong, I wait for it.
但对于你错的时候，我等着呢。
Eileen says she and Noah have had hundreds of conversations about the lockout and about Allendale. Sometimes he's still angry at Eileen. He says he wouldn't make the same choice she did.
艾琳说她和诺亚就锁定事件和阿伦代尔进行了数百次对话。有时他仍然生艾琳的气。他说他不会做出和她一样的选择。
But then again, he's not sure exactly what he'd do differently. He gets it was hard. If 19-year-old him could talk to 14-year-old him, he'd try to explain that.
但话说回来，他不确定自己会做出什么不同的决定。他知道这很难。如果19岁的他能和14岁的自己对话，他会试图解释这一点。
I would say, look, peanut, don't give your mom trouble. Don't give your mom trouble about this. I would say, look, your mom really did the best that she could.
我会说，看，小花生，别给你妈添麻烦。别给你妈添这个麻烦。我会说，看，你妈真的尽力了。
I asked Eileen if she'd do something different now. She says sure, but she doesn't know what either. She can't see a different turn she'd make. The thing about living in a broken system is you make broken choices.
我问艾琳她现在是否会做些不同的事情。她说当然，但她也不知道是什么。她看不到她会做的不同转变。生活在一个破碎系统里的事情就是你做出破碎的选择。
Shannon Heffernan, she's a reporter at our home station, WBEZ Chicago.
香农·赫弗南，她是我们的主电台WBEZ芝加哥的记者。
Act Three, Amricani. So a bunch of us heard this story, and we just really liked it. And like everything else in today's program, it's about somebody in an impossible situation. Sharif Youssef put this together.
第三幕，美国人（Amricani）。所以我们中一些人听了这个故事，我们真的很喜欢它。就像今天节目中的一切一样，它是关于一个身处不可能处境的人。沙里夫·尤塞夫把这些放在了一起。
He now makes radio for a living. But this is actually the very first radio story he ever attempted. He did this back when he was in college. Here he is.
他现在以做电台为生。但这实际上是他尝试过的第一个电台故事。他是在大学时做的。他在这里。
When I was five, my whole life changed. My mother lost her battle with cancer. We had no money. So Dad and I moved back to Alexandria-- Egypt, not Virginia. I had lived in Egypt as a toddler. I knew I had once called it home. I just didn't have any memories of that home.
五岁时，我的整个生活改变了。我母亲输掉了与癌症的战斗。我们没钱。所以爸爸和我搬回了亚历山大——埃及，不是弗吉尼亚。我小时候曾在埃及生活过。我知道我曾称它为家。我只是对那个家没有任何记忆。
We couldn't afford the private American school, so I went to an Egyptian one. It was my first day in the first grade. I was six now. My Arabic was limited to yes, no, apple, and toilet-- which is toilet, so it doesn't really count. I was terrified.
我们负担不起私立美国学校，所以我就读了一所埃及学校。那是我一年级的第一天。我现在六岁了。我的阿拉伯语仅限于“是”、“不”、“苹果”和“厕所”——也就是厕所，所以它不算数。我吓坏了。
When we arrived at the school's front gate, Dad gave me a hug and told me it would all be all right. I desperately wanted to believe him. I walked toward the mass of kids running around the yard and looked back over my shoulder. He was the only parent at the gate. He waved and gave me a thumbs up. I waved back and turned before he could see the tears roll down my face.
当我们到达学校前门时，爸爸拥抱了我，告诉我一切都会好起来的。我非常想相信他。我向院子里跑来跑去的孩子群走去，回头看了看。他是门口唯一的家长。他挥了挥手，竖起大拇指。我挥了挥手，在他看到泪水滚落我脸庞之前转过身去。
That morning, like every morning, we gathered to sing the national anthem. I didn't know the words. But the tune was catchy enough.
那天早上，像每个早上一样，我们聚集在一起唱国歌。我不知道歌词。但曲调足够朗朗上口。
[ARABIC SINGING]
（阿拉伯语演唱）
I could feel my classmates pointing and laughing behind my back, whispering, [SPEAKING ARABIC] In class, we sat three to a desk as the teacher went through her lesson. Two kids to my left were talking. The teacher, Miss Mona I think her name was, turned from the board and called them to the front.
我能感觉到同学们在我背后指指点点，窃窃私语，“（阿拉伯语）”。在课堂上，我们三人一张桌子，老师讲课。我左边的两个孩子在说话。老师，我想她叫莫娜小姐，从黑板前转过身，把他们叫到了前面。
They went and instinctively, if reluctantly, put a hand out in front of them. Miss Mona grabbed a ruler from her desk and brought it down on each hand. At this point, I distinctly remember thinking, oh, [BLEEP]-- or whatever the six-year-old equivalent is.
他们去了，本能地（虽然有些不情愿）伸出一只手放在他们面前。莫娜小姐从桌上抓起一把尺子，重重地打在每只手上。此时，我清楚地记得心想，噢，（消音）——或者六岁孩子相等的词。
Fast forward a couple months, I was picking up the language quickly. I think I was doing better in Arabic than most of my classmates, actually. I was even getting used to the kids being hit, though it never failed to grate on my nerves to see it happen.
几个月后，我很快就学会了这门语言。我想我阿拉伯语甚至比大多数同学都要好。我甚至习惯了孩子们被打，尽管看到它发生总是让我心烦意乱。
In my religion class one day, the teacher asked us all to show him the questions we were supposed to do for homework. He didn't assign us any questions. "Everyone stand," he said, as he picked up the ruler lying on his desk. We did.
有一天在宗教课上，老师让我们所有人都给他看我们应该做的家庭作业问题。他没有给我们布置任何问题。“全体起立，”他说着，拿起桌上的尺子。我们照做了。
He wound his way through the aisles, starting on the left side. I was on the right. "Show me." He stopped to read. "Good." Wait. How the hell did that kid know we were supposed to do these questions? Did I miss him saying it? Or was he just some sort of overachiever?
他穿过过道，从左侧开始。我在右侧。“给我看。”他停下来读。“不错。”等等。那孩子怎么会知道我们应该做这些问题？我错过他说的了吗？还是他只是某种超额完成任务的人？
"Show me." "I didn't do it," replied another kid. My palms were sweating. Maybe I could show him an old assignment, and he wouldn't notice the difference. He was already in my aisle. Maybe I could pretend I was sick. No, everyone would just make fun of me.
“给我看。”“我没做，”另一个孩子回答。我的手心在冒汗。也许我能给他看一个旧作业，他不会注意到区别。他已经在我的过道了。也许我能假装生病了。不，每个人只会嘲笑我。
Getting closer, right behind me. He stood in front of me, his dark eyes darting between my face and my notebook. "I didn't know we were supposed to." [SPEAKING ARABIC] he said. "Give me your hand."
越来越近了，就在我身后。他站在我面前，他深色的眼睛在我的脸和笔记本之间徘徊。“我不知道我们应该做的。”（阿拉伯语），他说。“把你的手给我。”
Tears were already falling onto my notebook, blurring the blue and red lines of the painfully blank page. But before he brought the ruler down on my pale, pudgy hand, I saw something soften in his eyes. It wasn't quite empathy, or even sympathy. It was pity.
泪水已经掉落在我的笔记本上，模糊了痛苦的空白页上的蓝色和红色线条。但在他把尺子打在我不成熟、苍白的手上之前，我看到他眼睛里的某些东西软化了。那不是移情，甚至不是同情。那是怜悯。
He looked at me and brought the ruler down with about a tenth of the force that he did for everyone else. I sat down, shaking, not sure if the glares I was getting from classmates were real or imagined. I rubbed my hand to numb what little physical pain was there. But that didn't help how I was feeling on the inside. [SPEAKING ARABIC] Very, very [SPEAKING ARABIC]
他看着我，用比打其他人轻大约十分之一的力量落下了尺子。我颤抖着坐下，不确定我从同学们那里得到的怒视是真实的还是想象的。我揉了揉手，想让那一点身体上的疼痛麻木一点。但这并不能帮助我的内心感受。（阿拉伯语）非常，非常（阿拉伯语）。
Sharif Youssef, he's the technical producer at the great podcast 99% Invisible.
沙里夫·尤塞夫，他是出色的播客《99%无形》的技术制作人。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put our program together include Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Dana Chivvis, Emily Condon, Stephanie Foo, Michelle Harris, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作。制作我们节目的人包括艾尔娜·贝克、埃莉斯·伯格森、达纳·奇维斯、艾米丽·康登、斯蒂芬妮·富、米歇尔·哈里斯、金伯利·亨德森、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、阿尔文·梅拉思、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的总编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（感谢辞）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to every show we've made, more than 600 episodes, for free. And as of this week, you can also find us on Instagram. Yes, we really jumped on that bandwagon.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们制作的每一个节目，超过600集。而从本周开始，你也可以在Instagram上找到我们。是的，我们真的赶上了那股潮流。
We waited eight years to see if it would catch on. Our username there is the same as on Twitter, @ThisAmerLife. Just search us, OK? You'll find us there.
我们等了八年看看它是否会流行起来。我们的用户名在那里和Twitter上是一样的，@ThisAmerLife。搜索我们就行，好吗？你会在那儿找到我们。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he saw a puppet show this week. He said the puppeteer was definitely substandard.
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他本周看了一个木偶戏。他说木偶师绝对是不合格的。
His hands were very visible.
他的双手非常显眼。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。